all right yes uh-huh
what's up everybody welcome to Griffin
what Griffin live I hope it sounds good
it probably doesn't something when all
this [ __ ] by myself so it's all
complicated but if you hear me you know
look at me I'm you could probably see me
doing [ __ ] I'm not supposed to be doing
on the screen
I went live too early but it is what it
is wait let's see wait I'm on the
computer you know got a nerd here with
me so here we are I hope you guys hi
welcome to RIF and what Griffin live you
know I hope it sounds get it and yeah as
you know I want to thank y'all watching
yo favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
all right y'all that was I hope that
sounded good so I am live you guys are
probably late in the chat right now you
know wait let me get my phone so but I
will do a quick question and answer I
have some questions from Instagram that
I want to answer but I know the audio is
messed up right
damn the sound is doubled okay wait let
me see if I can fix that
I think I can fix it live okay the sound
is double okay so let's see how we don't
fix that yeah how we go easy okay I
gotta go here okay and then we turn this
all the music's works if I turn this
nope because then I can't hear okay so
turn that back on oh [ __ ] wait okay
man this is a nightmare like the whole
thing is a nightmare trying to get this
[ __ ] to work has been Janice the the the
freaking bane of my existence
now I can't hear now I can't hear damn
it
can y'all still hear me
I know I'm getting this okay
hold on y'all hold on y'all see into the
underbelly of how this works right here
[Laughter]
this is so freaking frustrating try to
get it to work when you're doing this by
yourself
man wait let me see wait wait wait okay
okay all right here we go you can hear
me but does it sound doubled now oh wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait man I'm telling
you you go live trying to get it done
and it just messes up okay the voice
changer thing see that's not supposed to
be happening that's what's freaking
frustrating right now okay so let me go
on here let me go to the let me go to
that audio oh man this is just okay
audio interface we want it to be just
this I think okay hello no cuz I'm not
hearing this still if I do this hello
I'm not hearing it well this is my whole
life
this is my whole life
try to make your work and it doesn't
work
okay the normal mic is not supposed to
be making these noises and stuff y'all
I'm telling you you're supposed to be
able to hear me you know that mean but
now I can't hear myself in the thing and
I don't know what I did but I really
appreciate you guys being patient we
will answer questions I mean I really
probably should have got this like I
should have done a test run first before
I just went live so that's fun right
that's fun yes yes okay so wait let's
turn that off oh wait wait wait wait
wait wait I get it if we do this you
guys still hear me hello okay you guys
can hear me right I'm in I'm also using
logic that's the stupid part so I was
trying to record alright and we look at
the chat okay so is it fixed like do you
not hear the echo anymore
and I've been cooking a lot of meals
guys I've been uh okay I fixed it huh
okay wait wait wait did I really fix it
are you guys just [ __ ] with me come
on it could be real so I can get this
right you know what I mean I got to get
this right okay so we fixed it okay is
fixed but the problem is is I don't hear
myself here so that's kind of
frustrating because I want to hear
myself in in the headphones but wait let
me see something
okay I fixed it but how about this do
you hear the effects on this do you guys
hear the effects okay well whatever I
guess I don't need to have phones then
I'm not gonna use the headphones anyways
hey what's up guys
riffle Griffin live with all kinds of
[ __ ] technical difficulties technical
difficulties with Griffin so but anyways
um you know I have a bunch of questions
oh and the singing might has effects I
just can't hear it well that's fine who
cares but I don't want her to hear it be
able to hear the music and stuff right
but it doesn't matter um I got a bunch
of questions from Instagram
first of all just wanna say I hope you
guys are doing well out there sis you
know this is like difficult times I saw
the president talking today talking
about like you know what they're gonna
be doing with the stimulus package and
sending out all the ventilators and all
that kind of stuff and I know we're
concerned about if you get sick like
where are you gonna like is there a
hospital that's gonna be able to take
care of you so that's the hard part and
just so you guys know that it is live I
am looking at the chat right now so I
got my computer right here so you see me
looking down I'm looking at the chest
there's just a delay I know thanks I
know I'm looking a little skinny don't a
little skinny that's because I'm eating
healthy right now this just quarantine
is doing good for me but I got a bunch
of Instagram questions so I will answer
those but let's just oh wait wait I also
want to answer my
[Music]
patreon questions that I got you know I
got some patreon people let me see if
there let me see if they're on right now
let me see what those those people gots
to say but yeah you know it's like I
hope that they get the help they make
all these ventilators and I hope that
really I really want to hope the doctors
I hope the doctors like figure out some
kind of vaccine or something like that
like that's the main thing right I mean
because like even if they because even
if they go okay let's get back to work
or let's like you know get back to
normal life as best we can
if they haven't got a vaccine how can we
get back to work how can we get back to
doing not doing social distancing if
that's the case like a restaurants gonna
move tables out of their restaurants
where it's all six feet we're always
gonna be washing hands it would be
having gloves like what kind of world we
gonna live in so that's like a curious
that that that makes me that makes me a
little bit cautious like about like what
what's really going on here you know
what I mean so what do you guys think um
all right guys I know I look thin okay
Jesus Christ what is that
why is my head shaped this way you know
what let me see your head Leonard Lopez
talking [ __ ] in the chat you know what
Leonard Lopez is on timeout we putting
people on timeout quick we don't [ __ ]
around
put user on timeout and I'm slowing the
chat down cuz y'all going too fast so
you put you you saying stuff too fast so
we gonna put we're gonna enable slow
mode you know so you have to wait at
least 15 seconds before you send another
message so we can see we can see what's
going on here
Leonard is on timeout you will be put on
timeout like this you will get timed out
so stop talking [ __ ] all right what's
good no we're not saying that all right
let me see uh yeah you getting timeouts
not I've been eating I just been eating
healthier can I get thin can I get in
shape you know when I was in high school
I was like a hundred and seventy pounds
now
in high school y'all need just y'all
need to stop hating you know what I mean
all right let's see all right let's see
so question if you're gonna ask
questions
Alejandro shut up you know and then Rick
Glassman gave me this so now I got to
get one without the mustache or I got to
get one with grizzle I know I shift face
time Bobby right now that would be kind
of funny no I can't FaceTime them right
now but like they've been talking [ __ ]
on wait wait you know what we gonna go
do we go go to this [ __ ] right now I'm
gonna tell you I got I'm prepared to do
a lot of stuff right now so when I got
to keep the chat opening over here so I
could see the chat
let me check patreon no nobody says she
don't paid my patreon people don't care
oh here we go yes they do yes to do
hello patreon people passenger shaming
is one of the guys how are you staying
busy I'm hanging out by a thread hanging
by a thread
I sleep alone as studio apartment damn
if you're alone in a studio apartment
please don't kill yourself you know what
you should just like go for a walk it's
okay to go for a while you should do
like a daily walk I'm hearing that the
best thing to do is to have a routine
like wake up in the morning take a
shower get dressed like you're gonna do
something and then just like even if
it's just sitting on the couch watching
TV have some actions like make yourself
do the same things that you would
normally do that's important um how how
am I like in the electric car I love my
electric car but I haven't even been
able to use it you know I haven't even
been driving anyplace and my mom's doing
fine she just thinks she's not you know
she thinks she she's bored and wants to
go out and she keeps thinking she can so
that's hard for are you people out there
with mothers with like Alzheimer's
dementia and things like that I know
this is difficult times right now so
really you know I feel for you cuz I'm
cuz I I know how that is I'm dealing
with the same kind of stuff all right
let's go back to the chat
damn chat y'all going too fast but to
slow this down I know Bobby talks so
much [ __ ] about me it's really
ridiculous I'm seeing in the chat right
now it's really ridiculous how much [ __ ]
Bobby he's always talking I'm like damn
dude [ __ ] man I love them though I love
those guys Andrew and Bobby alright let
me go to this so I could show you so
this is all new and fresh for me right
now guys you know we're gonna try to I'm
gonna try to like work on this and make
it better you know but for right now
this is how we doing it okay boom all
right
so boom oh wait okay so let me go new
tab okay so let's go to friends podcasts
here we go yeah so watch this check out
check out this little thing I could do -
oh yeah look at that
yeah so these [ __ ] in this
episode which episode when they talk
[ __ ] about me I think they were talking
[ __ ] about me in this episode this
episode they were talking [ __ ] all this
video circulating now you guys can hear
it you know it's crazy y'all know what
you're like I can't hear you know what
what I want to know is what the [ __ ] is
going on with the bad friends podcast
set cuz it looked like somebody went to
Ikea like I this is like IKEA threw up
on their set you know what I mean like
what is this like what is all this what
is going on right there this is like
like what's that
QVC network it looked like Bobby's
selling [ __ ] on on the Internet get
the cat for $75 you could just cat
what's up with the flowers and stuff you
know why they did this they did just so
I can't green-screen into their stupid
podcast anymore that's why they did it
they did it they did it to try to keep
away from them you know what I mean ugly
[ __ ] is ugly ugly ass set for this
horrible friends podcast they are
horrible friends y'all know it yeah
check me out look at me huh oh [ __ ] I
shouldn't know switched over right there
see I don't know what I'm doing I
switched over at the wrong place
I should have switched over to this one
to see the chat right there we go yeah I
shouldn't have shown you guys did look
at me
this is a live live number one and we go
we gonna figure it out you know look at
that you guys were seeing the dam this
is crazy I gotta figure this out
you know we will figure it out guys we
will figure this [ __ ] out you know then
we just turn let me close that all right
what else should I look at on let's go
to Instagram actually let's go to
Instagram and see what Bobby let's look
at Bobby's Instagram right now see what
nonsense he got going on right there we
go let's go - Bobby's Instagram yeah
look at like this like what is this you
know what I mean what it like does that
look sexy at all I mean is there
anything sexy about this like this looks
like you know when you're going to a
dirty river and like you pull your arm
out and there's like a leech there's
like a leech sucking on you
that's what Bobby's body looks like
Bobby is shaped like a leech that's what
that looks like knocked out that is just
you know what I mean like he has a nerve
to talk about me like what what
[Music]
my god damn dude why why does his belly
and dick look like an upside-down
Arrowhead bottle you know I mean like
his it looks like you know I work like
some I just put in here he looks [ __ ]
weird as [ __ ] man how dare him talk
about me
how dare he talk about me okay let's see
let's go this is fun actually I like you
have a fun let's go look at we got to go
look at cheeto Santino let's go look at
let's go look at his [ __ ] Instagram
and see what's going on with him
they like to talk too much [ __ ] let's go
to let's go to his Instagram I see what
the hell's going on all right here we go
wait let's go here we go guys I'm doing
this all by myself so you got to give me
some credit
I'm trying to do this [ __ ] all by myself
all right let's see what Andrews got
going on right here my god just doesn't
look like a scary white guy Jesus man
that's just a face of terrorism right
there look at that [ __ ] yeah they're not
attractive men you know what I mean
they're just not you know you gotta
check out his show though you know I
don't I don't I don't know what's going
on here
like I'm not sure what's happening here
you know but it is what it is it's the
world we live in right now oh these guys
all right let's go to bad friends there
we go
there it is there it is oh this is
exactly what I sent them I mean this guy
got nothing on Bobby you know what I
mean
does that look like that looks like
Bobby and Steve got morph together and
just do this crazy check out this dude
oh my that's my favorite the last look
he does every time that's my favorite
[ __ ] I don't know all right let's just
get back to this let's get back to this
Q&A y'all do this Q&A all right okay
starting now guys if you have some
questions for me in YouTube I'm gonna go
- I'm gonna go to some of these
Instagram questions I got okay Oh were
you able to finish the scenes you were
doing with the scary face makeup yes I
did that movie is called Val it's a it's
like a scary comedy that's coming out I
had this weird prosthetic face mask on
as she was she was scary or spooky Oh
actually I could show you guys let me go
to my Instagram here we go hold up let
me show you what that [ __ ] look like I
think I still have a picture of it on my
Instagram let me see let me go to my
gram let me go to my green mm-hmm here
it is yeah there it is all right so let
me go back and we show you guys boom
yeah so that's the movie called Val that
I was doing so they got this scary face
maker but you know I was like a like a
well I'm not gonna give away the story
none of y'all see it anyway so it don't
matter but you know it is what it is so
that's fun stuff all right let's see
what else we got here um what video
[ __ ] oh the video still oh you right
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] damn it dude
oh no I closed way to reopen this
oh now I'm not gonna be able to go back
to that okay well no more no more
internet no more that stuff cuz I [ __ ]
up okay um alright how did you look into
the bunker buddy she falling well that's
my girlfriend Rachel love me some Rachel
so thank you for that what games you
playing I'm playing a war zone and I
just got my first solo victory in war
zone love that game that is my [ __ ]
game
let me look on YouTube real quick
alright it's getting scary out there
Grif I'm not sure the country is going
to recover from this your thoughts no I
think we're gonna recover don't think
like that guys if you're thinking out
there that we're not gonna recover no no
no no no stop thinking like that because
back in 1918 when we had the Spanish flu
fifty million people worldwide died from
that we weren't medically equipped we
weren't just think 1918 think of all the
things that have been invented since
then look at me touching my I don't
where I wash my hands yeah this is I
don't think this is gonna be like that
because people are recovering if you
look at the people that are died listen
I'm not a doctor I'm not trying to
pretend to be I'm just saying just look
at the statistics and the facts and look
at what's going on we're trying to stop
it right now you know we're trying to do
our best to like make sure there's
medical care because that's the real
problem right now is medical care
there's not enough medical care so we're
gonna recover we've recovered from worse
we've recovered from racism and we've
recovered from wars we've recovered from
so many things guys like believe in the
country we've even if you're not a
supporter of Trump and you want him out
and when he gets out will recover from
that let's say he steps up and does a
better job and he gets us through this
then you know we're gonna recover like I
have faith in the American people in
this country that we're gonna recover so
don't feel like that right now okay and
I do still play call of duty
call the duty for that booty where's
your beard and I can't grow a beard
beards are terrible on this guy you know
what you're getting you're getting
tunnel you about to get on timeout he's
about to be on time out one more
[ __ ] like that you want timeout all
right it's goodbye to Instagram comments
do you have any strategies for keeping
material fresh being away from the stage
so long I mean I hope I'm not one of
these comics when I come back and all
I'm talking about is like what I was
doing during coronavirus but you know
we'll see you know it's like you know
this is this is what as a comedian you
talk about what's going on in the world
so that's what I'm gonna be doing so
we'll see what I do crack with Bobby Lee
and Andrew Santino if the world was
coming to an end
know what I want to be
if the world's coming to an end I want
to be conscience conscious and know
exactly what's going on right up to the
end I don't know if I want to even be
with them if it was the end and it was
just the three of us oh god imagine if
the three of us were doing a podcast
episode and that was the end of the
world
oh god be terrible you know I mean all
right let's see how's the clean shaven
life looking like a pimp yeah boy um you
know what I'm actually liking this I
didn't think I would like when I first
saw my face without the mustache I was
like what the [ __ ] cuz I've been like
this for so long but now I saw a pic
like I looked at last week's episode
where I had a mustache with Krista
Stefan DeStefano de Stefano and I was
like oh my god what who's that CHP
officer so I don't know could mean Steve
do a podcast together we're trying it's
just difficult but during these times
okay let's keep going
do you ever no no don't like that one
let's see I'm Lauren toilet paper can
you please send me some booty wipes got
some booty wide from this company I have
so many have a whole boxes and boxes of
booty wipes in my closet so I'm gonna be
good all right let me go to YouTube now
I'm going back to see what's going on
what's up okay I'm gonna say
how to people in YouTube what's up
Victor what's up all Suzanne how you
guys doing
you know what let me go to my patreon
patreon people what's up thanks for
support and if you guys want to support
me on patreon I would you know it's
Griffin with Griffin I would appreciate
that you guys are great everybody is
great I appreciate all these people let
me see let me let me take a look at I
want to give a shout out to all my
people on here you got to go to your
dashboard how do you how do you see all
the Batman I don't know how to do [ __ ]
man I really don't know how to do [ __ ] I
don't know I don't know how to figure
out how to see other people oh you all
recent activity oh thanks for the the
super chats yeah if you guys want to
guess any super chat go right ahead
I don't know how to look at that but I
am still playing call of duty let's see
I have no I have big front teeth that
makes me bad at kissing so when I flirt
I get so nervous to flirt back because
I'm scared of kissing poorly advice you
just got to own it dude you got to own
it benevolent 24 if you got big-ass
teeth that's making you know you know
what you do is like when you're gonna
kiss somebody when you're kissing
whoever girl guy I don't know your side
oh no your story let them lead okay you
can't be leading with big-ass teeth
because you're gonna cut somebody's lip
off so what you do is you let them lead
so you don't do much until they do
something and then you move your lips
and whatever to there and then you'll
find you'll find like you're having a
conversation with your lips so you'll be
able to do it just relax
you know what I mean I like all kinds of
music from from YouTube I see there what
kind of music do you like I like a lot
lots of different types of music I like
rap easy-listening I listened to
classical I got a whole Chopin playlist
on Spotify I listened to lots of
different types of music I you know it's
just whatever you're feeling at the time
I mean sometimes music sets a mood
you know I mean it sets a tone of how
you feelin so it just it's up to you um
yeah exactly I have a big nose like Joe
Kay said and you just own it
that's what you have to do I own
everything about me you know and even if
like even if somebody says something
hurtful about you you know it's like
that's just their thing don't let it
bother you I mean it is who you are who
you are just live in your own skin you
know it doesn't matter what people say
it's like [ __ ] it you know what I mean
just live in your own skin I've watched
so many shows guys I saw that on there
too from somebody wait we gotta go to
Smitty you got big teeth get that
mustache gay my god that must actually
gets in the way look if you have big
teeth and you had a mustache that [ __ ]
would just be it would be too much that
would be too much um if whatever do
another show like workaholics yeah I
would love to do another show
if the Hollywood ever gets back to
normal yeah well I want to be on a show
I want to do stuff you know what I mean
you know so that's how we do that
when will Bobby that you come on the
pike Bobby's already been on the podcast
if you look on my look on my thing
you'll see Bobby Lee's been on the
podcast many times so him and his
brother and Bobby's come on once
actually he came here and just talking
[ __ ] about my breaks I'm Erik Griffin on
every platform if you want to play video
games with me I'm Eric Griffin on every
platform Eric Griffin on ps4 Eric
Griffin on Xbox that's usually my name
I try to grab my name out everything can
you come to Orlando after everything I
want to come to on that door I'll handle
is a great city
haha this is sort of like an insult but
I love it
no matter how ugly you are at least you
don't have to look at yourself that's
their problem yeah I mean that's a
[ __ ] up thing to say but really the
important message is that's a you
problem like if somebody's talking [ __ ]
about you they don't like how you look I
don't like how you how you are
that's a them problem and you don't need
to worry about it
you know what I mean don't even don't
even freaking worry about it just do you
just do you you feel me
all right let's go back to Instagram
questions and then I'm gonna play this
Skype call that I have with my good
buddy mr. Gary Owen you know and I'll
still be here chatting with you guys
while we're watching that all right
let's see let's go back to this boom um
more questions from Instagram when do
you plan to do another movie review I
don't know I haven't seen that many
movies and I don't know when I'm gonna
see another movie maybe I'll watch one
of these movies on Netflix that just
came out like they got that Mark
Wahlberg movie or maybe I'll watch that
and I'll review that movie what do I
think a war zone
I love war zone if I had to compare war
zone could player 2 black ops call of
duty 4 and war zone call of duty war
zone is it's it's more fun but it's also
easier I would say that it's easy
they've done some things to make it
easier to shoot and fire a name cuz call
of duty black ops blackout that [ __ ] is
still is hard that's harder that's the
hardest one so what's the most
artistically gratifying thing you've
ever done the most artistically
gratifying thing I've ever done and
that's hard I don't want to be cheesy
because I want to feel like I think my
podcast it's pretty gratifying because I
I do I do it all myself through all the
thick and thin through all the troubles
and trials and tribulations through all
the audio difficulties through all this
[ __ ] I do it all my [ __ ] self so
that's very gratifying but I think I'm
dying up here was a pretty gratifying I
really enjoyed I'm dying up here you
know if you want to send me a message on
Instagram too I suggest you do that
right now
I'm at Eric Griffin if you send me a
message in the thing right now
I'll get it right right this second you
know I'm saying so we'll be on there but
I think I'm dying up here was pretty
gratifying too because it was a what do
you call it a drama and I wasn't used to
doing drama so there's that all right uh
why do I keep ignoring you on IG live
because I'm [ __ ] cooking piece of
[ __ ] like
I'm cooking on IG live people want to
talk to me they act like I'm you know
I'm trying not trying to burn my food
when I'm talking to you you know what I
mean are trying to when I'm talking to
you who your comedic influences I have
so many I uh
Eddie Murphy number one there was a
reason why I just started doing comedy
it's I was always in my head that I want
to do what that guy does Martin Lawrence
actually - first comedy album I ever
bought was talking [ __ ] that was Martin
Lawrence's album but then I like Sinbad
George Carlin I like to Seinfeld I like
the different types of comedy because
you look at it like they're they're
different like Seinfeld is a wordsmith
so I liked it we'll see how he
contracted constructed jokes and then I
just like even some of my friends like I
like my buddy Johnny Sanchez super funny
Duane Perkins really funny dude you know
I got so many guys that I see it to
store that I think are just really
really funny some I don't think are
funny but I still enjoy what they do you
know on a scale of one to ten how good a
friend is Bobby Lee and why one to ten
how good a friend is Bobby Lee [ __ ] whoo
that's a tough one I Bobby is my good
friend but I wouldn't say Bobby is a
good friend if that makes sense I'll
just leave it at that maximum times
allowed to jack off in one day well I
don't know that's a really tough
question that's a really tough question
because it just depends on who you're
with like if you're with your if you're
with a loved one then you have to just
save that up because you know but if
you're like by yourself go to town
go to town you have car blanche to go to
town damn this is going longer than I
thought I was gonna go cuz I want to get
to know what guys let's get to this
Skype call okay so I want to see how
this I hope this works out I'm still
being the chat so you guys could tell me
how it's going but this is a Skype call
I did with one of my buddies and let's
check in with him mr. Gary Owen all
right another Skype call coming your way
I got my good buddy on the line mr. Gary
Owen hello mister how you doing buddy
thank you so
so bored out of your [ __ ] mind I
think the key to this is getting a
routine yeah you know I told my girl
said let's get dressed like we going out
on a date sit on the couch have dinner
with a candle watch a movie and then
like I'll walk you upstairs like we're
better than me you about to kill your
wife I hanging on killer but we don't we
ain't had no big arguments but the
littlest things could lead to stuff we
got to catch ourselves like oh stop we
bout to go off dude I know exactly what
you're saying like we just in the
kitchen and if we just like bumped
shoulders by accident it's like why you
in my way oh boy we just had one a day I
go hey how come every day I've been home
a box has been delivered like what's
going on when I'm not home cuz I'm not
here half the time these boxes coming
every day like you order it every day
what kind of stuff she didn't know she's
just like regular dropping and yeah but
I heard offense it's all for the house
you know there's like that's for the
pool or this the humidifier for Kennedy
or daughter and she had a cold and these
are beach towels these are pool towels
like things like that it's not like it's
Gucci Louis Vuitton at least right
uh-huh but how you holding up overall
like how are you what's your feelings on
all this that's happening I stopped
watching the news man I'm like this I'm
gonna stay home and call me when it's
over
that's all I can do yeah you like so you
like an old grandma right now feel you
yeah cuz if you want do watch one day
watch Fox News for an hour then watch
CNN for an hour you'll be so confused
you'll know what's going on bro I did
that today like just like the guy that's
in charge of like distribution was
arguing with that lady on CNN today and
they just were like going at it and I
was like how is this helpful crap like
and then they're like the numbers are
going up we knew that
people test it like you're angling it's
a surprise I know I mean like okay so
when you look at CNN CNN I'll make you
believe that the government is
completely inept and they're not doing
anything and then right then you look at
Fox and Fox or make you believe that
like they're doing everything they can
and these are in place and it's just go
do we need just mix messaging
during a pandemic no Joe figure out what
the one time we should all be coming
together if there's any time to come
together now is the time to come
together like right 100 on that man yes
it's challenging I just you know I
always like to talk about how I don't
have a creative outlet and I realized
doing stand-up really keep kept me sane
so when I don't have that and I'm
walking around here now
I think that's leading to the reasons
why I'm fighting a lot with my girl oh
so far it's not too bad it's more like
an 11 day vacation but talk to me in a
couple weeks I gotta show you this funny
thing man so I was googling you right so
I was googling you and it says okay so I
hear you're all your pictures Garryowen
whatever and then you click to Gary Owen
link on Google people be complaining
about that to you but this is actually
Gary's website for months and we can't
figure out what to do we contacted
Google the the post the web host ah
they're just they keep looking into it
but I don't know what's going on with it
because that's how people do research
they go they just go to Google they put
type in a name and then they go I can't
find this guy do you know how I found
your website I had to go to your Twitter
and then on your Twitter link it says
Gary going calm and then I click that
that to get to the viagra no no I took
me to the rear wheel website finally but
I couldn't get there by doing a lot by
looking at the Google so people you know
people out there like getting viagra
because of you
do you miss you and stand up like
whatever you miss the most about regular
life just freedom - I'm like I'm one of
those paranoid people like I'm literally
the guy looking at you like don't touch
me
I don't know way in the house when boxes
get delivered they don't come in the
house for three days because I heard it
I heard that Corona can live on
cardboard for 72 hours
oh my god what I like box in the house
entry it sits on our front porch for
three days and then we bring it in you
just scared the [ __ ] out of me about the
boxes you know to me like it's like it's
like I I when I came back from that my
last trip was two weeks ago I was in
Chattanooga at the comedy catch ooh
nightmare first of all we we not gonna
[ __ ] about places again because we have
a hole I'll tell you why I'm a [ __ ]
because I was supposed to shoot my
special March 20th my next special but a
guy canceled like a month ago like the
insurance called the production team was
like we're not ensure none of your
camera guys and everybody to fly out the
burnt we was gonna film in Birmingham
oh wow oh I was supposed to do one night
at the comedy cats the week before just
to work on some stuff and we were gonna
two shows on a Monday and that's I never
been there so I was like well there been
I had an issue because it was like it's
an all-white audience mostly right for
me when I get there you just gonna be
there for you it's weird but for me and
it's the weirdest thing
so it was like mostly all-white and it
kind of separated you could tell the
corona thing wasn't super scary yet it
was actually a day away from being super
scary because that Saturday is when a
lot of my buddies cancelled all their
shows and went home
you know mmm but I stayed so the crowd
and then there was this group of black
people that came in he's like fire
fat black women and a dude
he had his fat black girlfriend and he
had a Santa Claus
a big black Santa Claus beard okay and I
hear the feature onstage and I hear this
dude he's doing that kind of thing when
he's like you know he's like going in
and I'm like oh god this is gonna be a
problem
and of course I go out and they they
won't shut up and then they start day
like you Yami you know it's like my
problem was there was no security oh
there's no security there's no nothing
it's just me and of course all of these
why people are scared out of their mind
you know there's I can tell so so when
they finally left I'm talking to them
like was y'all scared you know no cuz i
dude was getting aggressive and i was
like him why did I was so max I was like
why did it have to be only black people
I was so mad like why are y'all doing
this to me there's like you fake black
it was all going in on me and I was and
it just had me in my mind like why am I
here
why did it why didn't I just go home
what am i doing so it was just like
that's my experience but dude it's a
great dude he's a lovely man I like him
a lot this is last Saturday you know
Saturday before so yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah because I was in DC at Constitution
Hall on Friday and it got shut down at
five o'clock shows it ain't right
and then night I was in Norfolk Chrysler
Hall that show went off that is yeah
that was the last night that Saturday
was the last night anybody was doing
shows that was it yeah and then I was
shooting a movie in Oklahoma City so I
flew back to Oklahoma City Sunday and
they canceled production as soon as I
landed they said dude did you fly back
I'll let ya they go [ __ ] oh damn we're
uh we're about halfway through the movie
so we got a whenever this clears up
we'll finish it I guess hey but what if
you look different you gonna be fat
haha I'm letting build deeper out - this
is over - shave my mustache people think
I'm crazy
actually we start to look like this is
the flu Manchu yeah you got your flu
Manchu going on yeah man flu - yeah just
all the production's closed down all the
like our whole business is shut down you
know I think everybody's guy I'm hearing
even like I think there's some of the
comedy clubs are not gonna be able to
reopen they're not gonna be able to pay
their rent so they're not gonna be able
to stay open some of them are gonna
close I heard some sad news out there
I'm here and they're gonna and this is
rumors I don't know is they're probably
gonna ask like for someone like me lower
percentage deals you know instead of
like 90 10 or 85 15 are gonna yo can we
do 80/20 or 75 25 or something like that
dude did we tell you what I think is
gonna happen - for sure they gonna take
full advantage of this situation and
it's never gonna necessarily recover cuz
I remember during the housing crisis and
all that happened that's when they
started that it was like they lowered
cuz comments were making a nice money in
2008 going to clubs and stuff and then
you know then this should happen and
then all of a sudden it was like deals
got lower they were like oh we have to
lower the what we're paying everybody
and they never recover from that they
stayed it like you had to be like a real
big draw like yourself so like were you
getting a certain percentage deal so
this is gonna happen again they gonna be
like come on Gary 50/50 but you know you
know it doesn't affect features yeah
they just make the same amount of money
for 20 years I know isn't that [ __ ]
crazy that's what's crazy I know I was
saying that to one of the guys that
worked at The Improv oh so yo man this
has become a hobby like it's already a
hobby for some comics because they can't
make a living out on the road but ten
well like what are they doing now I know
a lot of comic friends of mine who live
in gig the gig you know what I mean yeah
and living beyond they means - by the
way you know got a car they shouldn't
have living at a place they shouldn't be
at I've been frugal [ __ ] I've
been frugal for a long time so I'm good
right now
but like I know a lot of people don't
don't act like that yeah I'm good I'm
glad like I'm not even trippin really
I'm like my cost of living isn't my
house is already built so all my big
spending sure is my backyard of my house
the backyards paid for and I'm just
doing the house payments now I made such
a big down payment on the house when we
built it like I'm good I said I even
said I said this pandemic couldn't have
come at a better time personal and
career-wise because one I'm doing
finance him doing well enough I can I'm
cool for a couple months - my kids are
teenagers I never see him Oh
diapers holy [ __ ] now did you saw I saw
a video where his kid was like bouncing
on the bed keep on the bed had no uh
frame so they was in a run-down
apartment he had a diaper on and then
another kid came in with a diaper
Fraggle oh [ __ ] she look like to do
crazy pitbulls
attacking the old lady I think people
are finding out it's a challenge in
every relationship possible in your
house this [ __ ] is challenging that
especially like you know we seen he like
I was watching uh I was watching
Instagram live and like Justin Bieber
went live and he's playing video games
and he just has the camera set up all
you see is the back of his head but I'm
like he's in this big-ass room you know
by himself and I'm like well great like
the people that got like multiple rooms
and like but like yeah people that live
in like New York that's why I think
that's why the virus is spreading so
fast in New York it's because of that
small confined living all I'm sure share
the same airspace and vents
yeah there so of course it's gonna
spread faster New York yeah I never I
don't I'm not I'm not a I have family
that live in New York and I just don't
like I just don't like you know when you
go you ever go like Christmastime in New
York I'm one of those times and you all
get on the street like people's face is
like this like to do next to you is
right this close that person is close
and you like hello can I get some space
did it stinks
smells like you know [ __ ] all the time
like I like New York's all about are you
socially tapped in the people you're
with right oh yes especially New York
though cuz there were years I went there
girl whose place sucks and then I
started to meet the right people to send
me to the right spots as far as like
restaurants and lounges and everything
else now I enjoy it but I've never
wanted to just live there I like
visiting but I can't imagine a time like
this
woo yeah I know I don't know what that
must be like at least cuz people are
already like you know you already feel
stir-crazy you already feel you got
cabin fever as it is I mean it's just
like damn but like where are you getting
you most your information from like cuz
you you know what but what about the
boxes and all that where do you get your
information from Twitter so you just
okay
are you following like that The Cove aid
now and then but Twitter and then when a
doctor comes on that I like I'll check
hear that follow a couple doctors on
there you know I think guys she like
that well yeah I like the impartial
doctors they're like this is really what
it is yeah I know what you're talking
about then once it just gave it to you
like yeah we might be I like the ones
that like make it worse actually cuz
when I can have that in my head like you
know those ones that'll be like yeah we
might be locked up for six months you
like oh oh yeah yeah I know what I'm
saying but if you hear that I rather
hear that and know that if it's two
months then we gonna feel good but if
you don't tell that's gonna be a
weakling like hey Trump don't tell me we
gonna be back to work in April and then
we're not gonna be back to work till
June like make up your mind facts that
if Trump said suck my dick they'd
probably do it I know you know I love
you know I'm I'm really interested to
see how supportive Fox News is really
gonna be during these times you know cuz
it's like the more that comes out their
mother say like the more than gonna be
like oh we can't say that cuz 7,500
people just died or like what like how
much is it gonna be partisan do you
think it's ever gonna like where we
really go with the two networks they're
gonna be like hey we're on the same page
No
it's it's almost like watching ESPN
where you got Stephen a and Max
Kellerman really and I've done that show
a couple times but I don't sometimes
don't think they really believe it I
think okay you say this and I'll say
this it's almost like when I went on
there was a TV show called Bethenny a
couple years ago or last for one season
but they always had like three guests on
I don't know what Charlotte made one
time and it was some about relationships
and Charlemagne said what I felt but I
had to say something different because I
looked at Michael day that's what I feel
but now I say something different what
we could just be like yeah well
Charlemagne said right right but that
would be like people would be like I
guess that's not that that'll make for
good TV but like they they're on
different network I just I just feel
like at a time like this partisanship is
not what we need I mean I was really
like I wish there was some dr. Network
we could watch like like the Discovery
Channel I wish it was like you know just
MD like WebMD was a what was that was
the station and then they write and they
would just be like okay here's how you
get it stay away from this this is
what's happening this is what's why
people getting sick be careful this way
and that way that's pretty much what it
is it's like stay at home and then let
me know when it's over for real how does
it how you pair your parents alive or
how are your parents grandparents and
what you got going on I wish my stepdad
would catch that [ __ ] damn he's still
[ __ ] would guess the corona he then the
age group to is over 65 [ __ ] them music
to my ears
I'm I yeah my mom and stepdad they're in
like a little independent living place
you know so I keep trying to you know I
tell her hey don't go out you know let's
just stay at home cuz it's like I hate I
hate even thinking about it you know
what I'm saying oh like my wife's mom
she lives in a 55 and over community and
nobody's got it in that neighborhood so
there but every time like it's it's
literally it's the neighborhood next to
mine we got I live in a gated community
and it's the gated community next to
ours it's like we live in the
neighborhood next to my wife's mom oh
that's cool and
so we can just walk down there and every
time I take the dog out for a walk or
something I leave our neighborhood every
time you see the older people you always
keep your distance and not you're scared
of them you're concerned about them so
you're just like yeah yeah it's like
because if they have it they wouldn't
even be out they asses would be on a
ventilator in an in a sort of solo room
someplace well we live
I think there's I think there's only a
hundred and eight as yesterday 180 count
in any County we live in in California
oh sweet sweet sweet
well I'm hasn't run rampant so yeah my
parents are in Oxnard I don't think it's
I don't know if I haven't heard about
that but I just was scared because of
that thing I heard in Seattle you know
there was that old folks home in Seattle
then like one person yeah then it was
like thirty you know and then they all
died you know I mean and I was like oh
my god that's all you need it's like but
my parents live in a place they have
their own place you know they got their
own apartment you know it's just
connecting everybody there's older they
got a cafeteria so now they're just
picking up their food from the cafeteria
from the restaurant you know I mean but
everybody's got their own house so
that's a good thing
oh it's the owner those got you oh
people they think not over 55 and over
they can um they can all stay in their
own home oh and it's like a gated
community type of thing yeah yeah good
for you so you should I guess you must
live in a good place that you got your
Amazon stuff just sitting out on the
porch for three days it's gay listen I
live in a gated community and I have the
ring and I got a dog really and and I
got nosy neighbors let you know hey I
when I got like I also got to tell you
when I got back from a comedy catch I
got I put my suitcases down and I got to
freaking Lysol and I forget like Lysol
to my bag wiped it down took my clothes
I'll put him right in the wash cuz I was
on his plane nobody was was anybody on
your flight it was like practically
nobody on my flight I got to upgrade the
whole weight I had a whole row in
first-class I was like 17 people was on
my club
hold on it was 5 and it was only 5 and
first 12 and coach-house like a magnet
come up not a riffraff oh yeah one guy
and one guy was that dude
Gucci sweats Louie Vuitton backpack
Jeezy's gold I go but he was a coach I
go ok you that are you doing what do you
yeah I know G what what are you doing
back there I can't stand that come on I
can't stand people truck they're people
that travel fancy like what do you what
are you doing like when you have a Louis
Vuitton like suitcase you a damn fool
you know you think they don't always
lose Vitalis let's make sure we put put
that in the in in the back of the plane
in to say in a fancy area no they
probably taking that stuff even more you
know I mean yeah well I got it I got a
Louie Vuitton roller
oh but carry that with you but even
still what are you doing with a little
guitar roller oh oh I put it for me oh
she got it so she got it sent to the
house let me as much as you bag on it
you do give it to pay for I've had that
thing for years and it still is
brand-new all right you know and it is
it is a rectangle thing it's a black
roller and it fits in every overhead and
it don't look like it will but then you
put in there every overhead if it's
perfect there's this one little flight I
get I fly United what airline do you fly
Delta mostly there's this one plane
though that goes like let's say you it's
like less than an hour you in the
Midwest or something like when I had to
go to Chattanooga I was on this plane
that I carry my xbox with me and I had
this carrying case and it would have fit
in the thing and the lady was like well
you got put I said I'm not putting this
under the plane like this is the
electronics like why why do I did this a
what can you fit in there Aloha bread
and that's it
so I had to put it under the seat and
put my backpack but I mean I can't stand
those little okay whatever that jet is
don't be don't call it a jet if you
can't keep [ __ ] in the top yeah my
Louboutin what if it
it would fit its little way to fold it
down went right in here your bougie
community with your nosy neighbors I'm
doing this from the in-law suite oh
you're like nobody's even in this part
of the house
Oh keep the comma just like that go back
go back to the other side yes sir you
know what I'm saying
you stay on that side there you go did
you keep your like you I like you look
like you on my shoulder so what do you I
think I think perfect world we're back
to work mid-may realistically I think
June yeah yeah I agree okay but okay I
think we need to get back to do a comedy
and all these things I think we're gonna
need it's not gonna be right away let's
say today they went we have something we
figured out a way to slow it down or
like when are people gonna feel okay to
be around other people like that that's
what I'm saying like let's get gonna be
right away I don't think you'll run out
to the comedy clubs right away what do
you think you know it'll take a couple
weeks it'll take a week it'll be a slow
arm just like it was a a slow shut down
it'll be a slow go open up all right
restaurants are now open so 9 oh right
right you can have lunch you know the
last thing will be the mass gatherings
right right that's the bad part
right right right it'll be I know buddy
Sports will come back with no crowds
effort you know I got yeah I had some
clipper tickets I want my money back
yo I was in Oklahoma City when when
Gobert tested positive oh yeah and at
that point Oklahoma City was ground like
nothing they had like four cases in the
States and nobody died and all minor
cases then he got it everybody start
freaking out in the city well not when I
was in Chattanooga so like the the
Friday I go I walk to a restaurant to
have lunch and they
they said they hadn't had any cases but
they were being affected by because I
went to this one like barbecue spot that
they told me to go to you know you're
like oh that's the famous barbecue but
anyway the owner comes over because they
recognize everybody recognized me from
working hot whatever and they were like
oh she was like she's already lost a
bunch of business like all those like
catering events because they have like a
hall all that stuff was canceled and
it's they're just really reinvent the
business now is like everything's
takeout everybody's like you know doing
that I mean are you all are you guys
basically cooking at home are you still
ordering out yeah well I did try and
popeyes chicken for the first time the
chicken sandwich that's how special or I
was like a just give me a published
chicken sandwich it was good I wouldn't
leave my line three hours for it but it
was good yeah I don't but it's wrong it
wasn't it wasn't it was I yeah it was
good though when you ain't had it great
it was that's like chick-fil-a there's
always lines at chick-fil-a here in LA
like I'm talking about like the
drive-thru was like around the block
look that's the [ __ ] chicken sandwich
in and out and chick-fil-a there's
always gonna be a line no matter what
time just know in and out I don't I
don't I've never understood though the
in and out crazy either and I'm from LA
I love in and out but and once I pull by
it in and out and just three cars for
come out there's other [ __ ] the other
since this pandemic it and it out still
open around here so you've got you want
your day to go by fast just go to now
and you'll be there three hours waiting
so goddamn long somebody took a picture
from posting social media go holy yeah
it's literally the Fresno you have to do
you know you know you're not going to
work you're not going to like you got to
get back to work you don't got to get
home you just like let's go into chicks
let's go in and [ __ ] in an outline at
the social distancing yeah press have
you been to the store well how the
stores run in your area yeah I don't you
don't go out at all got you I haven't
left I left my house once since I've
been home just you just walk the dog you
walk in a neighborhood and that's it I
walk yeah what's a dog in a neighborhood
I left once because my buddy has his own
gym and he said I can come pick up some
equipment for this stuff so that was
good he hooked me up oh right yeah I
want you to storm once because I just
needed I was felt like I wanted to get
some more vegetables and things like
that and it was crazy because it was
like they got they got tape on the
ground everybody you know like you six
feet here six feet there six feet there
you know and he's just like and then
everybody's a little bit like Leary like
you know you see somebody coming at you
and you're just like yeah you're right
for saw me like we got we live in a
cul-de-sac so every now and then
everybody just hang out in the
cul-de-sac will bring lawn chairs out Oh
safe distancing but my neighbor hit my
shoulder oh my god Wayne and changed her
hope you weren't rude about it oh no I
just looked at him he was crazy and then
I got another neighbor who's very
friendly but he's he's kind of fan fans
on me a little bit when I come out cuz I
haven't really I don't know I don't know
my neighbors that well so now I'm
getting a note and the guy every time he
I told my wife I could watch him he
keeps eating closer to me and he's
always next to me when we're talking and
he's a close talker when he starts
drinking no keep getting closer and
closer like dude he literally got leave
I gotta leave dude he's getting too
close
what's the etiquette for that like oh we
had a point now we can be like yo I need
you to sir I need you to take four steps
back
are you there now here yeah cuz he's a
nice guy and he doesn't know we're not
that mean thing to say Joe I need you
Korona distance Western first like it's
a joke but then he keeps doing it keeps
coming closer I'm like and then we gotta
we got a golf cart hand was just on it
you in the back water blast in your own
your golf cart yeah
yo homie did I get off my [ __ ] bro yeah
we got it we got it we got to come up
with a way to like because I hate it we
had to be like that I hate that people
don't just like hey man you don't know
what's going on like I talked about on
my other other episode I'm at the store
and this girl sneezed and I'm like hey
sneezy Magoo you you know don't act like
yes just the way she did it it was like
she's laughing with her boyfriend like
okay like yo dude like you just go oh
you don't mean well they they saw I saw
one on one I don't know what where I saw
the news or something a lady sneezed all
over the the produce section and being
cover knows 35,000 gone $35,000 worth of
fruits and vegetables gone because they
were like what they gonna do oh and just
to clear everything 35 you know it's
crazy before it is you saw that kind of
[ __ ] all the time
all the time you see and you would you
would actually still buy the [ __ ] that's
how weird it was you know to meet you'd
be like oh you ain't gonna put it in the
bag like I gotta watch this when I get
home but we wouldn't even a thing now
look at us
I look two things I think you're gonna
take the hardest hit once this first
clears up one Golden Corral
who the hell's going to a buffet two
asian massage parlors that bus let me
tell you something I've been leery of
buffets anyway if you think about like I
always think like you go to a buffet
everybody's touching the spoon and get
everyone you know so you get the spoon
to get your thing they put the spoon
down there now they tell you and then
they go to them I don't know what people
are doing I don't know if you going to
the bathroom I don't know if you washed
your hands so every time
go to buffet I was always asked for
wet-naps I asked for like a big stack of
wet naps and I'll be like I'll be like
every X when I get my food I come back I
wash my people do my hands clean the
plate clean the fork and then I eat but
it's a yeah
buffets been nasty for years facts and
then like vague and then it's like Vegas
like I can't I really want to see what
Vegas looks like with NOLA with the
strip just closed I haven't seen any
pictures or anything they cancelled my
July date already oh really
I said what are they coming back hey my
agent told me don't don't risk it
because that's the that's the city
that's gonna take the longest to come
back always Bailey for entertainment
purposes Wow I mean gambling people win
their money back immediately oh that's
true yeah gambler don't be gonna be a
thing I know I have it I don't see any
pictures I'll try to see if I saw some
pictures some recent pictures of what it
looks like right now cuz it's like
Beauty I don't know your view is going
Gary keeps touching his face because I
am left my house homies I'm okay to
touch my face at this point I know
that's the other thing too late you you
don't even realize how often you touch
your face oh my god I had no clue you
don't know you in real life how about
this like like you haven't gone out but
I went to a place to pick up food and
I'm looking at the guy so first of all
when I was in comedy catch I already had
this situation because I've you know the
lady had gloves on and then I was gonna
hand her my credit card she was like oh
no I'm not gonna touch your credit card
she turned the screen around and she
sliced it herself
and as you let me do it I did it myself
and I thought oh [ __ ] yeah a lot of
people touch your credit card you give
people your credit card and you put your
credit card in your wallet I said on my
last episode wash your wallet wash your
credit card wipe that kind of [ __ ] down
so it's like you know your phone and
other stuff but then like I went to
another place the guy had gloves on and
he's working with the register you know
and then he goes over to the food area
and I'm like yo man you gotta change
your gloves yeah you know it's like all
that kind of stuff is in my head now and
I hate that yeah yeah everybody's gonna
notice um my name is gonna change
everything now actually the way customer
service jobs are I know 3 if I'm playing
that [ __ ]
I just wonder I wonder I hope we can get
back to even when this is because like
unless they come up with a vaccine this
is still gonna be a thing like even
that's what I'm trying to say is even if
we come back to doing work unless they
have a vaccine in June how's that gonna
stop people from getting the corona
virus I think it's gonna be a I'm
guessing a year before we got a handle
on it I mean we'll be back to work but
I'm guessing around a year before like
we got this we're good right which you
get it it's not a death sentence if
you're older right here to let this
whole cycle run through and everything
else well you know Michael yo got it
yeah I heard yeah I just I I hit him up
yesterday just so hey man sending out
some love hope you good and he's good
now you know but he was like really
really sick so it was like him I was
like I didn't hear about comics Guinea I
mean that's what's happening it's gonna
touch all of us you know that's the best
one cuz you know people have to think
it's a hoax some people are like I hear
I see some lot of [ __ ] on the
internet people like there's just a
liberal way to turn us into socialists
it's like are you [ __ ] kidding me not
stupid right now it's just saying so
once people die what someone wants
someone that you know you have one
degree of separation from when that
person dies that's when people are
really gonna understand the importance
of this social distancing yeah without
question no question it's scary man yeah
it is I could tell you I could see on
your face are you hunkered in and ready
to fight from from home like you like
[Laughter]
[Music]
your neighbors come knock on your door
you like well we can't use that anymore
I'm wiping down the damn doorknobs and
[ __ ] what you know what I heard also was
like some people were sick in January
and probably didn't know they had it
right we're just they got better but it
just had to run through their system but
how many people probably that came in
contact with them yeah I come that's
what I'm wondering I'm wondering how
many people actually yeah how many
people actually had it are we people
like I even had like I had a bad sinus
infection for a month you know and I was
you know that was like three month
to go you know it was affected my voice
and stuff and I was like now you looking
back at all that kind of stuff like
temples did I have it or you know you
know you know but like if cold and flu
season is that gonna be now the new
corona season you know what I mean like
next year I'm December January people
gonna be like well your owners are
coming around again well I got sick like
three times over like four months I
still was able to perform get me to but
I'd like tell them my you know my
romantic go give me vitamin C and boy
look oregano and all this other stuff
and then um I just got better but then
I'm we can sing again so I'm about my
mind I'm like damn that I have something
right I know that's about everything
anyways alright anyways listen um Gary
thanks for taking a call I want Mona I'm
a check in with you again in a couple
weeks cuz you know we still gonna be
here doing this and I'm still gonna be
cliche I want to see how that looks go
for that tank Abbott the old UFC
fighters all lord please come up with a
come up with a polite way of telling
your neighbor like a man or anything
going out you mister oh boy
confrontation like the first person I
talked to him for days and you bout to
wipe down your computer it's gonna go
viral I don't want to go s real viral
yeah alright well thanks for taking the
call Gary and I will talk to you soon
brother and you stay well man and peace
and love to the family I'm gonna take
care you too brother
oh boy alright guys that was a Gary Owen
comedian extraordinaire he's he's
hunkered in and uh you know that's how
it is right now so but anyways thanks
for watching
all right there it is there it is
that was a mr. Gary Owen y'all I hope
you guys enjoyed that
which at y'all a little bit behind but
you'll catch up in a second
huh let me just finish off some of these
questions that I got from people let me
see oh wait actually people have been
asking me some questions on Instagram
Instagram chat tray don't know what the
hell that is
don't know what the hell that is boom
let's see I just want to say thanks for
making these hope your mom as well I
appreciate that
oh don't want to go live everybody don't
you hate when you don't what somebody's
going live and you press like the
notification comes up and you hit it by
accident and then you jump into
somebody's live chat that you don't give
a about that's weird
okay let's see sure when he was on no no
Neil Burnham was fine we had a good talk
love Neil that was a good that was a
good episode who's your favorite
stand-up um I don't really necessarily
have a favorite you know cuz I get just
I see so much stand-up I just I like I
like a lot of people but they all morph
together it'd be great ah does it ever
feel surreal being a comic at the level
you're at along with being on such a
massive show you know it's weird
sometimes but you know I worked hard for
many years so I'm not surprised other
new jokes come in when this all ends I
don't know there might be but anyways
listen guys I appreciate you guys
watching me live like this I've just my
first time doing it so there was some
technical difficulties I will get those
stress I will get those sorted out
before we you know I'm gonna get those
sorted out
you don't mean I can't figure out what
exactly it is but we will we will get
those sorted out
you know I don't know what it's gonna
take but I'm a play with it mess with
to figure it out so you know we can go
live the reason why I was a little wonky
because I have just for the technical
people out there so I'm using my
streaming software but I have a Mac so
for some reason this version of the Mac
it the the softer the streaming
software's can't collect system audio
out so what it has to do is you have to
use a separate program called I show but
anyways so that grabs all audio so this
is like an output issue so then I have
Logic Pro going and I want it and then
Logic Pro is where I get the effects for
this live you know but I could use my
machine I just then another problem I
have is I have one of these performance
K machines but the problem is this type
of I want to be able to use a mic that
turns off and on but this particular mic
doesn't work with the machine properly
and it messes up so then I gotta use
logic so I can go whoa whoa you know so
then the output of that is going to the
system output now this is all boring
technical nonsense but you know I'm like
I say I'm figuring this [ __ ] out but at
the time I do it again so I want to do
like a recorded episode where I record I
you know get my thoughts organized Skype
with someone and have that episode out
and then go live you know at the end of
the week while we going through this
process and then I'm also gonna do a
separate secret live for my patreon and
my YouTube members so if you're a part
of my youtube your part my patreon you
know thank you so small number of people
but I don't care I appreciate you guys
whatever a little help helps me make the
show better it's all I really need and I
appreciate you so if you go to my
website Eric Griffin calm or patreon.com
slash Eric Griffin I'm gonna be
streaming on my gaming channel Eric
Griffin gaming so you could check me out
there too it's Eric Griffin gaming not
just Griffin gate because it was other
Griffin gaming so I had to so I made it
Eric Griffin gaming so which is great
because my initials is eg G and
way that's my real initials so Eric
Griffin gaming it just works out so join
my finger be an egghead alright before I
go I'm going to the chat here see what's
going on here but you [ __ ] troll
pieces of [ __ ] I appreciate you guys to
all the good people but blah let's see
Griffin I just seen you a murder-mystery
what was it like being with Adam being
by Adam Sandler Adam Sandler was great
really great guy to work with
fantastic just producer he just
understands what's going on like there
was a scene where like I'm we're walking
and talking and then like the camera guy
said something about we're in the wrong
position and Adam was like no no this is
not right we should be like this then a
guy looked at it again he was like you
know what you're right he's just an
idiot savant about how to make movies
guys great I hope they're making a
sequel not gonna would that I'll be in
that once everything starts up again I
know my podcast is perfect except the
audio I'm working on an audio [ __ ] okay
I'm gonna figure this out um I actually
figured out a bunch of stuff cuz I got
the time to sit here and like go over it
but anyways I don't want to keep going
because we've gone over an hour as it is
already I really appreciate you guys
listening to Griffin with Griffin
[Music]
watching me live again if you want to
watch me game go to Eric Griffin gaming
thanks for being here with me live it
was a whole technical difficulties
episode but I will work the kinks out
it's the fun of this that's what I love
doing it I love the challenge so I'm
gonna figure out how to get this right
for you guys for me and keep watching
keep sending questions now for next
Friday I'm gonna do another live next
Friday so make sure you put your you
know sent email you can email me oh [ __ ]
actually you know what I got a emailed
question let me go to this email
question yeah yeah I'm so glad I
remember that email where's this guy's e
oh no that's not it wait I'm gonna find
this email
we gotta find this email we got a
fondness ha ha ha ha
[Music]
um way I'm sending out emails wait I
gotta find this guy's email damn I feel
bad if I don't say this email wait here
it wait wait wait wait look I'm all by
myself
I don't got I don't got a George I don't
got a Jamie it's just me Tim no that's
not it oh [ __ ] oh here we go
yes Cory first of all other Skype calls
thank you having the green screen used
for the calls is great beats the heck
out of the basic split screen stuff okay
my question is what is the one good
thing that you've seen come out of this
quarantine we'll finish with that one
what's the one good thing I've seen come
out of this quarantine I mean I think I
think we're understanding the importance
of our relationships our friendships I
think that we're figuring out like
what's going on in our family unit like
if like we're strengthening our
relationships with our loved ones or
we're figuring out that this is eight to
one and and whatever little problems I
think this is forcing us to work them
out this is forcing us to delve deep in
ourselves and take conscious effort to
be better for ourselves and for our
loved ones and actually for our fellow
man I think the good thing that's coming
out of this if I think about it even
further is that we're taking the time to
actually look out for all of us we see
how this affects everyone and most of us
are trying to be like alright I'm gonna
do my part it's gonna be hard we're
gonna suffer there's gonna be people
that are gonna lose money in jobs
there's gonna be people that are not
gonna be able to recover but I think
overall we're all we're gonna recover
overall we're gonna make this work so
help out wherever you can and this is
what I'm saying about helping out with a
fellow man you know for me watching my
ads for me that'll help me because I
don't got no money coming in by the way
yeah I'm sure a lot of you guys you know
help out your neighbors you got an extra
toilet paper boom you got extra food in
the pantry you know check in with the
people that are around you because those
are that's your
new commute that's your community your
your solid current community so anyways
I appreciate you guys for watching
please keep subscribing please share and
if you have any thoughts suggestions
send me an email at Eric Eric at Eric
Griffin comm you know Instagram anything
like that you know you audio text out
there if you wanna if you got some
advice for me I totally will listen to
it now at this point cuz like you know
I'm trying to make all this work but
thanks again love you guys and peace out
peace